this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode jonathan is revisiting
microsoft's flagship shooter by taking a
look at the weaponry of halo infinite
another really fun weapon here and it
has two giant vertical bayonets on it i
mean the chances of you stabbing
yourself in the bits with it with this
are high i would say
if you want to see more of jonathan's
take on the halo franchise make sure to
subscribe as we've got a previous video
on the series iconic firearms and if you
enjoy this kind of content then make
sure to keep an eye out for our new
series loadout a show where we take a
look at the history and impact of some
of the most iconic weapons in gaming
from the m1 garand and the desi eagle
through to the minigun and the ak-47
naturally jonathan will be making a fair
few appearances over on that show too so
make sure to check that out right let's
look at halo infinite
[Music]
right here is our new polo assault rifle
looking very spiffy i might say
lots of interesting detail on it now and
for those of you who've seen our other
halo video controversially for me at
least conventional 7.62 nato ammunition
and actually we get a really nicely
modeled take on that now i can see it in
the magazine it's a conventional
completely commercial magazine just with
normal feedlits
reload is a bit weird so he's not he's
not holding it like a like an ar-15
magazine because it's it's short it's a
short magazine so he's he's cupping it
and inserting it like that but he's he's
doing it
back-handed super awkwardly i don't
really get that and that really this
brings me back yet again to this 762 by
51 problem you're not fitting 36 rounds
of 762 into that tiny little magazine
that is a 10 round magazine that he's
holding there but it is nice to see
master chief exercising some trigger
discipline with the finger nice and
clear of the trigger housing there
right the battle rifle very much along
the same lines they keep if it ain't
broke don't fix it and they are keeping
all the good stuff in terms of design
aesthetics we still got a
disappointingly 20th century actually
looking optical sight on there with at
least one more adjustment turret than it
probably needs for microscope of that
nature this and the assault rifle have
more than one inspiration i think we've
spoken about the f-2000 for the assault
rifle
and
the fam ass for the battle rifle i think
is despite this very much not being a
battle rifle this is an assault rifle by
any or any reasonable standard but the
overall look is definitely there we've
got the the big chunky front grip the
great big carrying handle the ballpark
configuration but that's kind of where
the resemblance ends as i think we
covered before really a very different
design in detail so there's a tendency
for and i'm guilty of this sometimes as
well to look at the silhouette of a gun
and say oh yes that's one of those but
when you when you look at it when you
look at as many guns as i do day in day
out you do develop an eye for the detail
and you can generally anticipate or
guess perhaps accurately hopefully where
uh artists have taken actual design cues
from a gun not just the overall
and i
don't think you can dispute that someone
saw a fam ass before they designed the
battle rifle but there's a lot more to
it than that
well this one's a new one on me the vk
78 i think is written on the side of it
it's an odd mixture of futuristic and
retro with the big ventilated heat
shield at the front and the the magazine
is just a sheet metal body with uh
witness holes pierced in it so you can
see the rounds in it almost looks like a
makarov pistol mag and then the receiver
is open so you can see those witness
holes in the magazine the sight's weird
as well because it looks like a reflex
sight quite chunky one for
for a future sight seems to function
like a like a zoo has quite a zoom when
you're when your eye goes to it and if
it's meant to be hooked into your helmet
somehow to give you that what appears to
be magnification or if i'm just
misunderstanding what's going on overall
look very reminiscent of the crisp
vector but that's kind of coincidence
because the magazine housing here is not
also the the housing for the recoiling
bolt which it is in the vector that's a
very specific design handling pistol
cartridges this is just a
very long magazine housing angled quite
steeply probably too steeply to work
effectively with rifle cartridges but i
don't know what the rounds actually look
like
right an interesting bit of alien kit
here reminiscent of some
60 70 sci-fi weapons maybe lots of
energy crackling around a revolving drum
we're not sure what that's supposed to
do there appears to be mechanical stuff
going on there's a some sort of bolt
moving back and forth on the back
obviously i don't know what that does
i'm not sure anyone would so yeah i mean
why not all bets are off aren't they
with future alien technology who knows
how it works i like the design though
something a bit different doesn't look
like a ripoff of anything else doesn't
necessarily look particularly halo
either
maybe it has like a distant franchise
resemblance to the magnum pistol like an
alien version of that that um only if
you squint
another weird gun energy weapon clearly
but operating and even sounding a lot
like a shotgun and it's got these
interesting fire modes vertical and
horizontal spread and the horizontal is
very much a sci-fi take on the vietnam
wall vintage shotgun duck build
attachment that spreads the shot to
increase the chance of hitting yeah the
being very creative here in um
in the designs not easy to do with a
long-running
franchise of anything to do something
new that doesn't break your established
traditions so i'm liking what i see so
far
that means more marines are in trouble
let's give them a hand
what an interesting gun hydra mlrs
m-o-m-m-l-r-s being a real-world
abbreviation for multiple launch rocket
system which i guess this is now
normally that means multiple rockets
launched at the same time and we're
talking here vehicle mounted artillery
rockets so this is like a man portable
take on that idea i guess interestingly
it's a sort of a tube fed drum i don't
know how that mechanism would function
your your thumbing
miniature rockets into a tube which then
retracts into the like each one is then
conveyed into
a chamber in the revolving drum
i think it's probably a bit fudged but
it is cool i like mechanically complex
looking things even if i can't get my
head around how they might function i'm
not sure why you wouldn't just load the
drum because these um these open chamber
type things are easily accessible from
the side so you could just press a
rocket into each one and advance it with
a button or maybe it would rotate itself
when you insert a rocket don't know why
you need the pop out loading gate slash
tube thing but it does look cool
[Music]
another really fun weapon here not
seeing anything quite like this before
it's a sort of revolver slug firing
shotgun handgun
thing almost reminiscent of a striker or
protector but well not really handgun
size but
hang on format and it has two giant
vertical bayonets
on it which is a bit odd i mean the
chances of you stabbing yourself and
you're in the bits with it with this
are high i would say uh i wouldn't like
to design a holster for this thing the
one criticism i i would lay on this one
is it suffers from lack of sighting
problems there's no obvious
means of sighting other than the add-up
display in the helmet which gives you a
reticle all times so as long as you're
equipped with that technology it's fine
how you'd aim it otherwise well clearly
you wouldn't and i don't know why it
doesn't just have a
gutter style close quarter sight on the
top of it potential slight issue as well
is these rounds appear to not be
retained all the way around the travel
of the drum or the cylinder so it looks
like they might be able to fall out
that's the problem needless to say
right the needler has made a comeback
and the needles are looking nicer than
ever very pointy and semi-translucent i
really like the way those are modeled it
really is just an updated take on the
original gun which brings with it the
same confusion for my brain as to how
the heck this thing's supposed to work
we've got what 26 rounds this is
supposed to have i mean maths isn't my
strong point but there are fewer holes
than that in the top of the gun i guess
it's kind of
using the crystals to create projectiles
and pulling them into the gun as it does
so like a like a glue gun but with spiky
shards of death that's the best i can uh
guess so anyone who's read the
background information on that please
please chime in
right a another halo handgun it does fit
the universe look although it's
recognizably
modern if that makes sense it doesn't
look like it's got it it's got a
visible extractor it's got serrations on
the slide it has a slide albeit not a
full slide uh some sort of aiming module
in front of the trigger guard a
conventional grip and trigger guard and
what looks like a mainly polymer frame
so it does look like an extrapolation of
a modern day semi-automatic pistol yeah
this thing seems pretty powerful some
sort of 10 millimeter round seems to
fire with some authority and to strike
with even more authority for a pistol
for a video game pistol it's got a lot
of
stopping power so i don't know if this
is a replacement for the for the magnum
or a uh parallel to it but um pretty
effective for a pistol
the banister mobilizing in a big way
how much longer
one gun down
two more to go
we are running out of time
the harbinger and the banished share the
same goal
right we've got to take on a plasma
rifle firing bursts now the usual
rationale for burst what two rationales
for burst fire with conventional
firearms one is to
save money
save ammunition at least and the other
is to increase to balance accuracy with
hit probability so by firing a burst in
theory you don't
transfer as much felt recoil to the
shooter and therefore more likely to hit
but then you're hitting with more than
one bullet or you're increasing your
chance of hitting with one of that burst
of bullets whether that applies to
plasma weapons i guess we don't know yet
it'll depend on how much recoil a plasma
projectile which we can call it that
would have because if if plasma has mass
but nowhere near the mass of a bullet so
i'm rambling now but i don't think that
there'd be a need for best fights
right the spanker has made a comeback
m41 which is a designation that should
only ever be used for the pulse rifle
sorry i still don't understand how this
thing's supposed to work it looks like
they fixed the rotation issue that was
confusing before but
this is some sort of rocket system but
it has a lot of recoil uh which looking
at it i guess it would because if it did
it's not really a rocket is it it's
basically a um
handheld artillery piece more than
anything else and for some reason it
rotates the the barrel or launch tube
from one to the other to fire one and
then the other can't imagine a system
that would function that way if it's a
rocket launcher you only need the tube
it's in and just an electrical impulse
to fire the rocket because the rocket is
the weapon the launcher is just a
launcher it resembles anything it's a
grenade launcher because grenade
launchers are not recoilless uh and
they're not rocket projected they are
giant cartridges and that's really more
than anything what this resembles which
would explain the recoil explain the
need to align the barrel with a breach
mechanism to actually fire the thing and
support the case less projectile till
it's fired that's that's my kind of my
interpretation of what this thing really
is even though when it's fired it
behaves like a rocket a bit of a puzzle
but it does point toward a potential
future there's already a conceptual
system for an under-barrel
missile launcher that gives you the each
infantryman the ability to fire one
massive projectile that
is then guided to the top
a visually interesting weapon this one
we've got that um signature blue glow or
some sort of energy weapon and some kind
of battery pack reloading system uh
slapping it in with the fist there and
injects itself goes flying out the gun
which yeah might make sense for the
magazine fed weapons in the right
situation but so far hasn't hasn't
caught on and actually if we watch the
round counter this thing's firing bursts
of energy
really really fast like a hyper burst
three four five thousand rounds per
minute rate of fire almost to the point
way i'm not sure why they bothered
because i'm not sure you're ever going
to get any spread of shot as it were but
um a very a very say unique looking
design which is hard to accomplish these
days whether it's substantially
different in gameplay terms i'll let you
be the judges on that one
all right we've got a new shotgun drum
fed not too futuristic looking i'm not
sure what's going on the side of it
there where the ejection port sort of
bolt area is or these
might be i think i'm looking at a giant
cocking handle it's i guess it's um a
little bit jackhammer isn't it sort of
space jackhammer the infamous video game
the gun that's more way more used in
video games than in real life the panko
jackhammer uh so pump pump a bit
skeptical about pump action skeptical
about pump combined with drum magazine i
can't think of a single example of a
drum fed pump action shotgun there's
probably a good reason for that the
whole mechanics of this are a mystery to
me because the drum is mounted very low
in the receiver normally when that's the
case there is a feed tower on top of
that truck goes up into the receiver so
that the top round it feeds down to one
top round is stripped into the chamber
and fired alternatively you could have a
drum where
it's a revolver so each
round is in its own chamber and the
chamber is revolved into alignment with
the barrel it's not what's happening
here because the barrel is higher up in
the gun so
really a mystery as to how this thing
feeds its rounds into a chamber to then
fire them i wouldn't be going on about
this if this thing wasn't using
conventional 12-gauge ammunition as it
proudly proclaims on the side of the gun
and therefore we have to think about how
how that would work
wow this thing is impressive the
appropriately named skewer because you
can skewer them with the giant spike
projectile that it fires almost like um
blade steak shotgun type weapons that he
uses or you can skewer them with the
conventional bolted on permanently
attached bayonet that's very gears of
war i think that's underneath the spike
that you can shoot so you're never short
of spikes on this thing a slightly
curious mechanism although i don't want
saying that this is a fictional spike
launching rocket launcher thing so i
can't really critique it at all but to
load the projectile in the munition into
the front and then operate some sort of
lever to seat it backwards and then
latch it in place i'd have thought you
either want to push that thing in place
till it locks or you want to lift the
latch up insert the munition slap down
the thing putting it in lifting it up
and putting it down seems a bit weird
but that's the way it works and then
we've got a whole clown car full of
marines on with these things and it's a
different version because the giant
spikes are also exploding so i'm
guessing you get a teacup saucer side a
diameter spike in your chest that then
explodes so i imagine it's how it works
but i suppose you haven't got long to
suffer at least
right the um or an updated version of
the the venerable well it's not a
material rifle isn't it it's got the big
carry handle on the on the chassis it's
a large caliber it's got a muzzle brake
on it reasonably powerful scope and
high-tech scope in this case and it does
that job well although we also see that
the likes of master chief can use this
thing as a glorified pinpoint shotgun
sort of so firing it from the hit
without the scopes using the reticle
and if you get the shot lined up you
don't have the spread of a shotgun but
you have the sort of insta kill effect
of of a shotgun and it's self-loading
it's semi-automatic so weirdly it almost
works like a shotgun we've got a view in
the scope and it looks like we've got
the option of five power or ten power
we've got a range finder i don't know
what the in-game functionality of that
is well i often find rangefinders
they're there for visual interest more
than anything they don't it's rare that
they help you in the game as they would
help a real sniper we've got
functionality in there we've got a wide
field of view which is not common for
modern
sniper riot material rifles that's
something that may come in time with
advanced optics so yeah i mean the
obvious advantage of that is you don't
have to come out of the scope or rely on
a spotter to spot other targets you can
potentially see your next target in your
field of view without having to do
anything else i suppose the only only
other thing i'd say is that um it
probably takes a spartan to use an
anti-materiel rifle as a melee weapon
uh join us again next week if you will
also over on the royal armouries channel
we have a series going there on firearms
and there's other stuff on there that
might interest you uh check out our
website as well social media come and
visit the museum if you're able to do so
so yeah thanks for watching guys we'll
see you again next time
[Music]
you